i'd like to welcome you to sergey's talk
thank you very much for the introduction
and uh thank you so much for joining us
yeah thanks everyone for coming to my
talk so this is going to be a very high
level overview of data modeling and data
processing techniques i will basically
try to compress down to 20 minutes
several decades of evolutions of
techniques in that space and also take a
quick peek into the future
so the focus is going to be on really
telling you about the key trends and
in a very simple language and also
showing you the pitfalls and dead ends
that some of those trends can end up in
and really build a common vocabulary
between people with very different
backgrounds and data
so as you heard from my background i've
been on both sides of the enterprise
data i've been a software engineer and
also on the analytics side of data
engineering
and what i've seen that despite data
being something that connects these two
camps
the the entire understanding of what
data is seems to be very different on
both sides and this seems to be
resulting in a lot of tensions and
inefficiencies
and i discovered that modeling time and
modeling how things change over time
seems to be at the center of this
problem so we're going to look at those
two comps from like data from both of
these perspectives
and we're going to start with ltp
so otp this is usually the source of the
data in the company this is your
application your service or your product
that you're giving to the clients
something that creates external value
for them
if we ask a software engineer to
implement a simple marketplace service
for an online video game let's say
something that to sell hats for example
right it doesn't really matter for it
for this example this is what the
results might
look like so we'll have sku with some
prices attached to them every ski you
might have one to several items
and users are gonna have accounts and
they will have some currency balances
and they're gonna have inventory
what i wanna highlight here is that this
is the default so if you
no matter which engineer you ask this
from junior to senior a vast majority
are going to come up with this exact
solution
because this is how we taught to view
data this is coming straight from our
school book straight from our database
courses
this model is of course non-temporal
because there is no time in in this
model at all it models the current state
so there is no time there's only state
transitions that happen through crowd
queries
so if we deploy this application and run
it in production we're going to start
wondering what it's actually doing like
what is actually it performing if we ask
simple questions like what it takes how
long it takes for a user to acquire most
of the content in our game this is not
something that we can easily answer with
this database model so this is what when
we discover that state is actually not
as interesting as dynamics of change and
analytics is all about time the
dimension that we decided specifically
to ignore and this puts engineers on a
long and windy path of introducing time
back back into the data somehow and they
invented a lot of ways to do so
so first two ways are really just top
gap solutions engineers might not have a
lot of time for analytics when they
launch the application something they
may say that oh we like capture database
backups every day so why don't you use
just those
so this is of course a horrible very low
frequency source of data you need to div
them together and
it's lossy you will not be able to
reconstruct any transactions from these
backups
the second solution change value
selection is just iteration on those or
we take incremental backups we push the
frequency from one day let's say to
every half an hour but it's still lossy
you will not see transactions here
so this brings us to a big contender
right change data capture that you
probably all heard of
it assumes that for every state table in
the production database we have a log
table that contains every single changes
that happened to the state table and we
capture this change either by triggers
or you or from uh replication logs
so from engineer perspective this is a
pretty cool solution they might say we
achieved the ultimate granularity it's
lossless it's transactional but analysts
might not be as
pleased with it because what they have
to deal with is this like this is
something what i call what happened game
they look at these log tables and what
they see is that in time t1 there seems
to be a change in account balance it
dropped by a hundred and they see that
an item was added to the user's
inventory so for looking from skus they
might infer that this probably was a
purchase transaction that happened
so really you don't want to be in this
position what happening here is
information was because what state
changed doesn't really tell us why it
changed such state changes are what we
call anemic they're we're seeing the
numbers changing but we don't know what
happened from the business perspective
so you don't want to be in this position
of reconstructing what happened like
your application is already doing this
hard work of translating business
transactions into state changes to
record them in a database if you're
going to be using state changes for
analytics you will be basically creating
this mirror copy of your entire business
logic on the analytics
so definitely not something you want to
do
so i think cdc really works on the wrong
level on the level where information has
already been lost and it's surprising to
me that it keeps re-emerging in all the
data processing technologies and often
being advertised as the best solution to
extract data from the broad databases
databases
uh because really i think
it might work in very few narrow cases
but it's not a good general case
solution i think the best solution in
this case is to not to lose information
to begin with
so this is uh what happens in the main
events which is a step in in the right
direction application still maintains
its state in a database but in addition
we have an event log table where we
capture
business
events so the data that we capture
actually speaks the language of our
business so the entire previous example
here can be captured as a single event
as you purchased that contains very
detailed descriptive information of what
happened
this solution might be pretty hard to
maintain from the engineering
perspective because in the application
you end up with this duality between
state and advanced
so
engineers might not be as happy with it
as analysts
so this brings us to event sourcing
which flips the entire problem on its
head instead of storing state we store
only history in a database and we
reconstruct the state on demand from the
events so having events like deposit for
1000 currency and a purchase for 100 we
can easily tell that the current account
balance is 900 right it's pretty simple
projection operation
state might still be stored in a
database but it's only used for
optimization for queries so here the
projector component might sit and listen
to all of the
history that is happening that is
written to the event store and
continuously update the state and a
projection database
extracting data from event store into
data warehouse really becomes a super
simple
operation because data is already in the
form of historical events it's ready to
be processed
so i really do believe that there's such
a thing as good data and it's the data
that speaks the language of your
business you should learn to recognize
and avoid anemic models
state projection really is just a
state is just a projection of history it
has information loss by definition so
it's not fit to be your primary data
model
and i think the defaults are obsolete
like why is it okay for us to lose
history or do destructive updates as the
first implementation i really believe
that something has to change in the way
we teach data to young engineers
because analytics really is the core
requirement not something we can bolt on
later
so what's going on on the analytics side
in the meanwhile
so all app has you know its analytics
it's focused on providing internal value
to the business usually providing
insights the drive optimizations and
the drive strategic planning
and for a very long time star snowflake
schema was the classic implementation of
data warehouse or also known as all up
cube or pivot table that allows you to
slice dice and drill down and up in your
data
and it's said to be really great if you
have clean and well structured data
at the center of it is the fact table
that just
records the events over time so here we
have transaction happening at t1 t2 t3
etc
this is a very dense table it's
optimized for high rate and high volume
of data and most foreign keys
most columns are foreign keys to the
dimension tables
dimension tables also known as slowly
changing dimensions have several
different forms but the most common one
i've seen is the one that uses validity
time intervals to capture change
so here we have a ski one that had price
100 from time t1 to t2 and then at t2
the price had been dropped to 15.
so it's been said that the seds are
great for data that changes infrequently
but you might ask yourself how frequent
is infrequent in our online game where
prices change once a week let's say
it doesn't sound so frequent to me but
if we were implementing data warehouse
for costco or for uh
for walmart where prices can change
hourly on thousands of skus at a time
that sounds pretty frequent right
also what's the reason for the change in
this case and ask you price uh why did
the price drop was it the promotion was
the expiration date coming up or
something else so this brings us again
to this problem of anemic data
what there is a problem for you it
really depends on your use case and uh
on your business
and the snowflake schema really has to
match closely your business needs
because the way you design it the way
you are detected depends on the
questions that you're gonna be using it
to answer so you kind of have to know
all the questions and anticipate all the
questions up front which is pretty hard
to do and in reality you probably will
not
so this in combination with snowflake
schema being really hard to evolve kind
of caused its downfall and the gradual
transition and rise towards elt and data
lakes
so x extract load transform uh has very
simple idea we grab the data from the
application and store it in the raw form
with very minimal processing
and then we use massive parallelism to
scan this data and analyze it on demand
so it's really interesting
this concept becomes good combination
with event sourcing because in event
sourcing our data is already in the form
of historical events
if we apply elt to it data lakes are
just becoming a very big event stores
they just store all the history of all
applications right
so this is a great indication to me that
otp and all app data models are actually
converging
temporality manifests itself not only in
how we model data but also in how we
process it and i think this aspect is
significantly less understood
so let's look at the batch processing
first
you're all familiar with batch ensure
because you do batch processing when you
use excel you do batch processing when
you query database or sql you do it when
you write your scripts and pandas or our
batch treats data as a bounded list of
records
so i'm going to switch up the example
and raise the stakes a little bit and
say let's
analyze and calculate the daily number
of copied 19 cases using a data set of
hospital admission records so let's kind
of try to recreate the statistics that
you're getting from the news daily today
we're going to do it from using a very
simple sql query right we're doing a
group buy
of all the cases based on date and we
just count the numbers of cases in every
bucket so by running this query every
midnight we can expect to get a
statistics that we want
and we're going to look at this from
using bi-temporal diagrams so don't
panic they're actually really simple on
the x-axis what you see is the event
time so this corresponds to the time
when some event happened in the real
world
so for on thursday for example we have
two registered coordinating cases
on the y-axis we have system time this
tells us when the event enters our
system or entered our database
so in ideal case we can imagine that as
soon as event happens in the real world
it immediately gets into the database
so this is what creates the zero delay
propagation
and this is what gives us this very nice
diagonal
so let's see how batch performs as this
in this idealized case
remember that we're running the query
every midnight so on thursday we run it
and gives us two on friday we're on it
it gives us one but also two because we
just rerun the entire batch query on the
entire data set right
and so on so this is looking pretty well
there's some redundancy going on here of
course but it's not a big deal right
unfortunately in reality this is not at
all how data looks like
because data can be late it can be out
of order it can be lost and then
backfilled or it can be run and then
corrected later
so um for example i live in british
columbia and rcdc does not publish any
data on coveted 19 cases on weekends for
example for some reason this is what
creates this big gap in the middle
and hospitals my enter
data on the night shoots on the next day
so on thursday our event might actually
be entered on friday
so if we apply apply batch to this type
of data on thursday we get one instead
of two on friday we'll get zero
and so on so we're getting a lot of
wrong results especially on weekends
but
what's worse we're also rewriting the
history so someone comes
to us complaining about the zero that we
got on friday the next day we're gonna
say like what's zero the zero does not
exist we just replaced it with one and
there's no record of it left anymore
so batch processing using batch
processing on event data really is
non-reproducible
because as results your results are
going to be changing as new data arrives
and the corrections that you're making
are not explicit nobody's going to know
that they happened
what's worse the errors that we're
seeing are mostly concentrated in recent
results and this is the results that
everyone cares about the most right if
you plot the graph of covered 19 cases
based on the results we just got we're
going to see this downward trend in our
graph
that is always going to be there on
every day
and uh if you're like me you're probably
already learned
from using like all the dashboard tools
to ignore this download trend but i
cannot honestly say that it doesn't
affect me like when i see the aerograph
like that i keep always thinking like oh
maybe maybe they are going down maybe
it's going getting better so i think
now imagine that politician looks at
this graph this downward trend that is
fake trend can be a difference between
imposing or lifting a lockdown so what
we do with data can actually matter a
lot
so
and if you try to explain this nuance
over these errors in data to a
politician i think all it's going to do
end up doing is undermine the
trustworthiness of data
because any slightest doubt in data is
going to swing people back to to their
gut feelings to making decisions based
on on what they perceive the
situation to be not on the data and this
is the opposite i think what we want to
do
so can batch be fixed
well we could introduce a one day delay
to the processing right but except on
weekends there we need three days of
delay
and also what about statutory holidays
there's probably something going to
happen there as well
so this is a lot of cognitive load i
think i will make a mistake for sure you
will probably make a mistake and this is
just for one simple data set now imagine
that you need to
join several of such data sets that are
updating on completely different
cadence and schedule
i think this is just becoming
incomprehensible and honestly i don't
even want to comprehend it because i
believe there needs to be a better way
to deal with this kind of problems
so what we're learning here is that
batch processing is non-temporal it
relies on completeness of data which is
not the case most of the time like it
pretends that time does not exist and
wants you to handle all the temporal
problems
it wants to wait for all these problems
to disappear before you start processing
so you get all the complexity and edge
cases and it's up to you to to now
resolve them
this makes batch processing very manual
if person walks away from batch
processing even if it's fully automated
it still requires a lot of babysitting
so if a person goes away it's just the
data usually stops for
the solution to this is called stream
processing and uh
the series of posts from tyler academy
in the blog
called streaming 101 is probably the
best time investment you can make to
learn about this
and the whole idea of it is that data is
treated as an unbounded stream of events
this means that processing can run
continuously and potentially forever
because because there is no such thing
as done state in stream processing as
such the results are emitted throughout
as the query continues
so let's look how stream processing is
going to work on the this messy data
that we had
uh this is how it's going gonna look
like so
not only stream processing somehow
magically gets all the results right
there is no redundancy so we get one
result for every single day and that's
it so exactly what we wanted
um and somehow like through this
green line
somehow seam processing knows that it
needs to delay the processing for a
little bit to get the result right
and this green line is called the
watermark
so the watermark is pretty simple
concept
that tells us that a certain system time
ts with a very high probability we have
received
the system has observed all events prior
to even time t so this is what gives us
this line on a bi-temporal diagram the
watermark can be predictive so a system
might constantly monitor like what's the
delay between the event time and when i
got the the
the event when the event entered the
system and it might adjust if
it emits too many corrections that's
probably a sign that it needs to bump
the watermark
but watermark can also be manual we can
have a fixed offset but what's more
interesting the watermark might be set
by the maintainer of the dataset
themselves
so a person who enters data in hospital
might indicate to us hey i just finished
entering all data like it's friday
afternoon but i finished entering all
data for thursday please go on with your
processing
so i think watermark is very beautiful
and powerful concept because it shows
you the underlinings of what data
processing actually is
and data processing really is just a
balancing act between correctness and
latency
so even in the event of severe event of
uh backfill like if we lost some data on
friday and only on tuesday discovered it
street processing can still handle it
and
uh create a correction
what's important
this correction is going to be automatic
and explicit so it's not going to be
rewriting the history it's going to be
the separate event saying hey remember
the data on friday i was wrong it's not
one it's actually four
because it's explicit it allows the
downstream system that consumes this
data to actually automate how it reacts
to these corrections which i think is
super powerful because it makes stream
processing more compulsive
so it's a widely accepted idea now that
stream processing is a complete superset
of batch it's a more complete and
intuitive processing model
that addresses temporal problems instead
of ignoring them so it handles all the
edge cases for you
and it gives you the power to control
the trade-off between latency and
correctness
if you want more correct data you just
wait more if you want data to be real
time you reduce the correctness
at the expense of getting more
corrections later
and it's more autonomous like we can run
write the query once and run it
potentially forever as long as data
keeps coming the query is going to
continue working
there's this
misconception i would say that stream
processing is only used for high
frequency data like
page views or ad impressions etc but i
think it's completely false like
incoming we have data pipelines that are
built with screen processing and look at
the data sets that i that update only
once per year and we still see a lot of
benefit from using stream processing
because i don't need to care about all
of these edge cases etc i know that
they're going to be handled
automatically for me
so where all of this is going like in
the stock so far we started with state
data and we saw how temporality intruded
through change data capture and later it
evolved into the main events of
outsourcing to more event-based form
and we saw that a similar trend has
happened in the analytics side where
snowflake
snowflake schema gave wave to elt and
data lakes also becoming immutable event
based storing entire history
and now stream processing that has been
evolving completely separately for a
very long period of time is giving
analytics all these interesting tools to
process the event-based data faster and
more reliably
there's also a lot of interesting
parallels and tools like uh version
control system and distributed ledger so
i don't have time to talk about but i
think that the whole space of data is
now converging on something that might
be called one true data or at least a
much better form of data and the ways of
processing data better
so the way i see it personally is that
we've spent several decades in this
local optima of centralized batch where
processing is very manual where the
latencies are high data is
non-reproducible and unverifiable and
we're slowly crawling out of this local
optimum
so we've seen that already we're going
towards event-based data this means that
it's a no-brainer that we're going to be
pushing
data towards more real-time pushing
analytics towards real-timeness and low
latency and to achieve that we need more
autonomous data pipelines and street
processing provides us that
the more complex our data pipelines get
the more it's
more important it's going to be for us
to understand where every single bit of
information came from
so
this is where provenance is coming
we need to be sure that the data we're
looking at can actually be trusted
the ownership of data is a huge deal so
data is going to remain actually
probably going to become more
decentralized
but data needs to be globally integrated
we want data from different
uh sides of the economy to be joined
together and process together so we're
going to be building more interoperable
data supply chains
so
from my perspective i spent a lot of
time thinking about this and i saw that
if we continue down on this path and
it's going to take us probably a few
more decades to reach this new state of
data so i decided to start a project
that builds
the system
the data management and processing
system from ground up in this new state
the state that i think is the future of
data
and this project is called open data
fabric it's a protocol open protocol
specification for data exchange and
processing and simply you can think
about it as kind of mix of git and
blockchain for data or csv on steroids
that has streaming sql built in it so
you can find this specification on
github and contribute to it
conceptually here's how it looks like on
the left we have data publishers that
are constantly supplying data to the
system and this data enters this
computational graph comprised of
derivative data sets so every blue data
set here is just a bit of streaming sql
that continuously processes data
so it enriches it aggregates it it
extracts some insight and in real time
provides data to decision makers to ai
and machine learning or for automation
people are completely removed from the
system so they configure these queries
but they never touch data manually so
this is what allows us to reach the
real-time speeds but also creates
uh properties like complete reducibility
verifiability and provenance in the
system
so really this is the system that allows
you to collaborate on data in a very
similar way that you collaborate on
software by collaborating with people to
write all these streaming processing
queries
um so odf data set and
the metadata is actually first-class
citizen of any data set and we believe
that it's actually more important the
data itself because metadata tells us
where data came from and how it was
transformed if we don't know those
things we cannot trust the data so data
becomes useless
metadata is also a ledger of events so
it contains events like hey data was
added or schema was changed or some
processing has happened or a query was
updated etc
so it creates all these very nice
properties one of them which is zero
cost stable references so you no longer
need to version your data you don't no
longer need to copy data to ensure
reproducibility of your data projects
all you need is just this offset and
ledger and you're done
metadata
yep oh we're we're down to uh like five
minutes we're gonna have a question for
you
one more slide and it'll be done yeah
all right
yeah metadata also enables the evolution
of data sets over time so queries can
change and schema can change without
destroying all of the downstream graphs
that have been built on top of it
so chemical why is the tool it's our
main product that we're building
it's the reference implementation of the
odf protocol and it's essentially the
world's first decentralized data
warehouse
it it's as simple to use as git you can
run it on your laptop and start building
peer-to-peer data processing pipelines
and collaborate on these pipelines with
other people so i believe that this is a
that simplest way today to try stream
processing if you haven't tried it yet
because you can write your queries and
apache spark and apache link sql without
having to set up these frameworks and
without spending weeks on figuring them
out and trying to configure them
so i invite you to check it out you can
just look up can we see a lie on github
and it's going to direct you through all
of our tutorial videos we have a very
nice self-serve demo with a bunch of
examples
and we also set up a discord server
where you can chat to us about stream
processing and uh data reproducibility
in general and
to conclude i want to highlight that we
kind of went for it full circle and
we're returning to the core meaning of
data and data is just a record of
observations it's our modern day history
book and you don't modify version or
diff your history it doesn't make sense
if you do any of those things it
probably means that you're working with
some derivative form or a projection so
which is probably not fit to be your
core data model
data is rarely frozen in time or
complete it flows continuously so we
should we should stop trying to archive
it and build data pipelines instead that
are reproducible we should embrace all
the temporal problems and embrace the
fact that data processing is a balancing
act between latency and correctness
and see that the batch processing hasn't
served us so well that it undermines the
trust and data and creates cascade of
errors and makes data
all way like to them manual
so i think we can do better we can set a
higher bar and revisit how we exchange
and process data
in order to achieve the reproducibility
provenance real-timeness all of these
properties are not something that can be
bolted on onto existing systems i
believe
so i invite everyone to collaborate i
think the next data revolution is not
going to come from enterprise because
for decades it's been too focused on
pushing things to be bigger to be faster
but they're not as interesting in
provenance and reproducibility
and i think the revolution is going to
come from open science and open data
communities so i invite you to work
together with us
thank you very much i hope it was
interesting and i'm ready to take
questions now
yeah definitely i'm not an expert in
your area but i can still
tell you address the number of
fundamental issues but
anyways we've got enough time for a
couple from anonymous
don't you think streaming systems are
more vulnerable towards failures and
might change
us to
lose our data at time
it really depends how you implement now
uh modern streaming systems kind of
might store state in their memory and
yes like they're more susceptible to
failures the way we implement streaming
in open data fabric is that we write
data as a ledger
uh onto disk so we persist it so if
system stream processing fails we can
always restart it at any previous point
in time so there i i don't think there
is any concern about failures or
reliability of those
uh all right and for the uh second and
last question
from sheila what do you think is the
main benefit of removing the humans from
the loop
we cannot simply reach the real-timeness
of data without removing people i i see
the current world of data as this huge
rube goldberg machine where one person
takes data processes it a little bit
expose it to another person and this
changes goes on and on so this is of
course very manual so if we
want like take the covet example right
it took
modern countries like the first world
countries
it took them up to eight months to build
this simple data processing pipeline of
just counting daily cases i think it's
absolutely absurd that it took us so
long so clearly something has to change
that i think this manual aspect of data
is one of them
ah excellent thank you very much for
your time thank you very much you have a
wonderful day you do bye-bye
you